now first things first just in case you
aren't yet familiar with scp-049
otherwise known as the infamous plague
doctor then we're here to bring you up
to speed it'll help you get the most out
of today's tale
scp-049 is a tall humanoid entity always
seen wearing long black robes a hood
over its head and a beaked mask
protruding from underneath the same kind
of mask worn by physicians during the
height of the black death however these
parts of the plague doctor's attire
aren't just a costume the scp foundation
discovered that all of
scp-049's outfit is actually part of his
physical body in other words the robes
the hood the mask they are all made out
of muscle and bone the plague doctor's
only real goal in life is to hunt down
any person it deems to be infected the
entity often refers to something he
calls the pestilence and upon sensing
this affliction in a human being
scp-049 will attempt to make direct skin
contact with whoever is apparently
carrying said pestilence the plague
doctor's touch is lethal killing anyone
he comes into contact with you might
think that's as bad as it gets that this
creature just goes from person to person
killing them via touch but you would be
wrong it gets worse killing one of his
victims is only the start afterwards
scp-049 then begins performing a crude
outdated form of surgery defiling and
repurposing the person's corpse using
equipment that he produces from his
iconic doctor's bag he injects a number
of unknown chemicals into a person's
carcass eventually turning them into an
instance of scp-049-2
in essence a vicious incredibly
aggressive zombie the most bizarre part
in
scp-049's mind this means he's just
cured you naturally
scp-049 is already held in containment
safely locked away by the scp foundation
at present scp-049 resides in a humanoid
holding cell closely monitored by
surveillance cameras for 24 hours a day
every single day the scp foundation used
to send its doctors and researchers into
scp-049 cell or would make a habit of
bringing him cadavers as test subjects
fresh bodies for the plague doctor to
hone his surgical skills the researchers
would keenly observe the doctor
transforming the dead into instances of
scp-049-2
but these researchers and doctors
working for the foundation weren't
exactly free of disease meaning every
time they entered scp-049 cell they were
at risk of receiving his deadly touch in
this cage with this deadly dangerous
doctor that spends all his time in
captivity that's where our story starts
but while you might expect a story about
the plague doctor to revolve solely
around violence disease and death this
tale offers a surprising divergence
boiled scrambled and fried is a story
about an unexpected new life coming into
existence in a frankly bizarre fashion
all starting in that tiny containment
chamber where
scp-049 had been held since the
foundation first captured him it had
been increasingly obvious to the
researchers observing him that something
was quite wrong with a plague doctor for
the first time since the doctor had
arrived in the foundation's custody he
appeared to have fallen ill unexpectedly
the security cameras that were trained
on him day in and day out recorded
scp-049 groaning in pain clutching his
stomach as he limped weakly around the
confines of his cell had the pestilence
finally gotten the better of the good
doctor was he too now infected the same
as the world around him the foundation's
medics were confused
baffled as to what could possibly be
wrong with the creature of course it
would also have been easier to examine
the doctor if they could easily touch
him without the risk of dying or if his
body wasn't made of skin robes
nonetheless the plague doctor was
brought to a medical station for a
proper diagnosis under the orders of one
dr richard omel a foundation doctor who
specialized in taking care of humanoid
anomalies and who had been assigned as
scp-049's caretaker the creature tried
to assure dr o'mell that he was strong
enough to withstand the intense pain he
was obviously suffering from putting on
gloves for safety dr o'mell felt a
distinct lump within scp-049's stomach
initially believing it to be a case of
abdominal distension this is a condition
that occurs when gases or fluids build
up in the stomach and cause it to swell
up and inflate usually as a symptom of
another internal disease but scp-049
reassured his caretaker that his
condition wasn't the result of any
disease and in fact it had even
apparently happened before dr o'mell
asked scp-049 why he had never told the
foundation about this or why the
creature wouldn't explain what was
happening i did not think you would
believe me so i said nothing
scp-049 explained doctor i am pregnant
i'm sorry but i can't explain it please
just let me return to my cell i need to
make the proper preparations naturally
this statement was met with stunned
belief by dr o'mell especially seeing as
the foundation had been observing
scp-049 through security cameras for
months on end without stopping the
creature couldn't explain tensing up and
breathing heavily due to suffering
obvious and intense pain as dr o'mell
rushed out to grab more members of
medical staff the plague doctor
continued struggling against the aches
letting out his loudest of cries yet as
an extreme bout of agony surged through
him a pearly white egg gently tumbled
out from scp-049's robes just as dr
o'mell and a group of foundation medics
arrived staring in shock at what had
just happened seeming to recover quite
quickly the plague doctor asked to be
unshackled and returned to a cell to
tend to the egg worried it would die
unless he was able to care for it as the
shock dr o'mell agreed as cp-049 gently
picked up the egg and cradled it in his
arms of course this all came as quite an
unexpected turn of events to the
foundation reports were filed and
archive entries had to be updated but
they allowed the plague doctor to keep
his egg and raise it perhaps just so
they could watch and research as it
happened instead of out of any sense of
kindness for the next five days the
creature was fixated entirely on caring
for the egg all his energy focused on it
he built a nest in the corner of his
containment cell out of fabric and paper
and would sit on the egg in order to
keep it warm during that time a number
of foundation researchers assigned to
watch over scp-049 reported that they
had heard clucking noises coming through
the speakers in the observation room now
assigned to watch and report on
scp-049's progress dr omel watched the
plague doctor from the observation room
connected to the cameras and audio
recording devices in the creature's cell
ever since the bizarre and unanticipated
birth omel had been given the task of
compiling an extensive report on
everything that took place within the
cell for the most part everything seemed
fine or as fine as something so unusual
could seem the egg was in a healthy
condition nonetheless although the whole
event had the foundation doctor
wondering
scp-049 had always had a somewhat
bird-like appearance helped in no small
part by that infamous beak-shaped mask
did the fact that this creature could
apparently lay eggs mean that the plague
doctor was some form of humanoid bird an
avian human hybrid that only mimicked
the plague doctors of old or had those
medieval physicians created their masks
to emulate scp-049
which had come first the plague doctors
or the plague doctor a debate as
confusing and cyclical as the one about
the chicken or the egg and now the
plague doctor also had
an egg i don't know about you but i'm
starting to get a headache just thinking
about it
scp-049 had begun to softly peck at the
surface of the egg when dr omel decided
to step in and look for some answers to
his burning questions over the speakers
in 049 cell he asked for an explanation
the plague doctor answered that he was
checking his egg for signs of life
within its shell as if that answer
should have been obvious and he had
succeeded there was definitely something
living inside as the plague doctor
returned to sitting atop the egg omel
asked outright if scp-049 was in fact a
bird it was uncommon if not downright
unheard of for a humanoid anomaly to lay
eggs like this after a moment's thought
scp-049 replied with no as far as i'm
aware i have never been a bird yet
producing eggs is natural to me he
explained that while this had happened
before it had been at least a few
decades since the last time then the
plague doctor went back to sitting on
his egg humming as it rocked back and
forth in the nest ten days passed after
the egg had first arrived and now
scp-049 cell was brimming with activity
foundation personnel had fitted the room
with a glass screen to protect them from
the plague doctor with researchers
piling in into the safe side carrying
cameras and hurriedly taking notes
protected by a number of guards the big
day had seemingly arrived whatever had
been brimming and brewing inside the egg
was about to hatch as the researchers
all whispered to each other with
excitement and intrigue
scp-049 stood protectively on the other
side of the room just waiting in
fascinated expectation the pearlescent
egg started to shake suddenly its pale
surface cracking the crack spread from
the center of the egg forking across the
shell like a lightning bolt over a dark
cloudy sky something underneath was
pushing through pressing outwards from
within the egg splitting it apart as it
had tapped and pecked its way to freedom
a small white beak poked a hole through
the shell that surrounded it piercing
the egg at last the creature within this
spawn of the plague doctor began to tear
itself through the barrier that had kept
it safe from the outside world until it
was ready to take its first steps with
both arms the thing tore itself out of
the egg all under the watch of the
foundation's doctors and researchers who
were stunned to see
another plague doctor emerging from the
egg it was small much smaller than the
father that had birthed it and cared for
it while it was waiting to hatch but it
was nonetheless a perfect miniature
version of scp-049
complete with the same kind of robes the
same beaked mask even with a little hat
on top of its head with a gasp of pure
excitement the original plague doctor
lifted up his new mini self and hugged
the child in his arms the excitement
that had filled the room up now quickly
dissipated as the audience of foundation
personnel quickly realized that they had
just witnessed the live birth of a brand
new anomaly of which they understood
virtually nothing as dr omel stepped
forward to cautiously ask scp-049 to put
down its offspring the smaller plague
doctor smacked omele's hand with a stick
before leaping from its father's arms
and dashing out of the cell as alarms
began to blare indicating a breaching
containment
scp-049 wiped a tear from his eyes
stating he
is the cure the new smaller plague
doctor now designated as scp-049-a
seems to have a talent for evading
capture by the foundation and for
frequently escaping containment unlike
its predecessor
scp-049 this offspring has a body
beneath its robes that is composed
mostly of moss watts of tissue and
smaller plague doctor masks during the
occasions in which it has been
successfully detained by the foundation
scp-049-j has claimed that it is in fact
a powerful magical doctrine wizard with
the ability to cure all that ails
mankind however to date it has been
unable to cure anything usually making
medical conditions actively worse my
headache included now go check out
scp-049 the plague doctor captured and
scp-049 what actually is the pestilence
the plague doctor questions and theories
for more on the not-so-good doctor